hey 42 here a lot of weird [ __ ] happens
in Russia this story is no exception in
the early 1980s a man by the name of
Alexander Salonika joined the police
force he was 5 foot 5 with a small frame
but was like no one else the police had
ever encountered before little did they
know the beginnings of something
monstrous had begun to stir within him
he had trained in the Soviet Army but he
was strikingly fearless exceptionally
lucky and his abilities as a marksman
were practically superhuman leading many
to suspect he'd actually been trained in
the Special Forces he was soon
distinguished amongst his peers for his
natural ability to handle criminals but
within six months certain oklee
characteristics were beginning to reveal
themselves people noticed that Sonic had
a ponch on for extreme violence sadism
and cruelty towards the suspects that he
caught and if you're upon Shawn for
cruelty is unusual in Soviet Russia
you've got a real problem it wasn't long
before 'selenic was booted out of the
police force and returned home to Kurgan
where he worked as a gravedigger but as
was later discovered Salonika was driven
by a singular obsession his entire life
he was consumed by the romantic notion
of becoming super human something more
than just an ordinary man it was what
had driven him to become a soldier then
a policeman and now he needed something
more he was accused of rape whilst
working as a gravedigger butts ilanic
escaped criminal justice by leaping out
of a second-story courtroom window and
fleeing to deepest darkest Siberia
Salonika fervor avoided justice by
cosmetically altering his appearance but
still in his private moments
he sought out an outlet for his
disturbing ambitions of violence and he
soon found this but not before the
police caught up with him and threw him
in prison though of course you can't
lock up a super human entity or at least
a Russian psychopath and sure enough
sonic managed to escape from prison in
the frozen wasteland of Tyumen Siberia
Salonika found a way to survive while
simultaneously fulfilling his lifelong
desire for power he became a contract
killer
but not just any contract killer whilst
anyone over a certain psychopathic
predilection can pick up a gun and kill
someone
Sonic was different he had already
proven he could escape seemingly
impossible situations but more than that
he was a fierce and vicious fighter he
successfully defended himself against 12
attackers in prison he would also shoot
with pinpoint accuracy with a weapon in
both hands
he took out rival gang leaders and
supposedly untouchable Moscow crime
bosses so lonex in gained a reputation
for his ability to kill anyone with ease
even when one target drug boss Valeri de
lugar was surrounded by 12 armed
bodyguards Sullivan still managed to
kill him slap bang in the middle of a
crowded nightclub Sonic's abilities soon
earned him the moniker the super killer
and his seemingly impossible
assassinations earned him a fortune but
the mob could never take him for granted
after all if they didn't pay up they
would soon be found dead eventually he
was captured by the police but sullen it
killed five officers during the struggle
and even managed to break free of his
restraints it was not long after that he
escaped from prison again it is said
that he slowly grew bored of contract
killing gun putting it behind him
retired to Greece leaving his mob
connections behind him and
with former Miss Russia Svetlana Kotova
whatever the truth he was eventually
killed by a rival assassin alongside
Kotova but to this day some believe he
faked his own death and he still walks
among us
Solan exploit inspired 9 TV series two
films free books and many many
documentaries and good or bad he became
the Superman he wished to become in fact
he's as close to the real-life version
of daredevil supervillain bullseye as
you could ever find in real life which
neatly brings her to the topic of this
video there are many criminals in the
world and countless examples of crime
barons from history but few very few
earn the title super villain but it
turns out that super villains do exist
in the real world either due to
grandiose beliefs romantic ideals
ambitions or twisted ideologies and the
real-life supervillains are more
terrifying than any in fiction whether
they're thieves murderers mob bosses or
men who just want to watch the world
burn these are dangerous and mysterious
people you would not want to cross we
all know Doctor Doom Lex Luthor and the
Joker but who are the super villains
from real life and just how dangerous
were they well what if I was to tell you
that Catwoman was real except she was a
Canadian guy Gerald Blanchard was on
holiday in Austria with his wife when he
visited an exhibition at schloss scum
brew and saw the CC star an enormous
pearl in case in a 10 pointed star of
diamonds within seconds of laying his
eyes on it
Blanchard knew he just had to steal it
his mind immediately began to identify
the motion sensors the depth of the
bulletproof glass the positioning of the
bolts and screws and layout of the room
the windows and a behavior and patterns
of the armed security details on patrol
he knew something as famous as the CC
would never be fenced how could such a
sale stay hidden but nevertheless he had
to steal it the challenge was just
irresistible slowly but surely
a plan began to hatch within his mind
the following evening
a small plane was soaring across the
night sky above the schloss schonbrunn
palace and out of the back of the
aircraft dropped Blanchard that's right
this badass was parachuting onto the
palace roof he descended through the
inky blackness until he set foot on the
rooftop that he'd noticed was unguarded
during his early a visit entering for a
window he had a locked the day before
and moving through the palace by stealth
Blanchard avoided the guards and made
his way to the prize the CC star loosing
the screws and taking care not to
trigger the alarms Blanchard fooled to
the precious sensor of the alarm by
using a trick worthy of Indiana Jones
himself he replaced a star with an
object of equal weight
the palaces own gift store replicas and
with that Blanchard with the CC star in
hand disappeared into the night the next
day when the star was revealed to the
astonished public Blanchard returns to
amuse himself by watching the on lookers
being bewildered by the beauty of this
cheap gift store knockoff it was weeks
until the real star was discovered to be
missing but by then Blanchard had
already smuggled it back to his home
country of Canada Blanchard was a
criminal mastermind exceptionally brave
cunning and creative he had a
savant-like ability to understand
security systems surveillance and
electronics distinguishing him from an
experienced but regular thief into
something far more effective
a fief from childhood Blanchard first
stole when he was six years old
swiping milk from a neighbor's porch he
was instantly hooked and his destiny was
sent later in his life when he was
caught and interrogated by the police he
managed to sneak into the next room
clamber up into the roof tiles and after
much of the station had stormed out of
the exits looking for him he descended
again
stole the police officer's uniform and
calmly walked out of the front door
tipping his cap to the guard but not
before leaving a single bullet on the
interrogators desk when a driver picked
him up and asked him why he was
hitchhiking dressed as a cop Blanchard
said he'd been to a costume party and
had a really fun time so began a long
and legendary criminal lifestyle he hit
banks for more than half a million
dollars he scoped them out during
construction and inserted devices into
the walls in crawl spaces to help him
including his own surveillance tech he
got himself a sidekick created fake IDs
marriage licenses and aliases stockpiled
security and law enforcement uniforms he
would sow confusion amongst the cops
trailing him by calling them and giving
them false but incredibly believable
tips and could rarely ever resist a
thrill of beating the system just one
more time eventually though he slipped
up after leading the authorities on
multiple year-long chases across the
world he was finally caught moments
before he executed the job in Egypt for
a mysterious martin known only as boss
the job went horribly wrong Blanchard
made one too many mistakes and was
caught on a wiretap apprehended and
charged with 41 crimes ironically for a
criminal as talented and legendary as
his reputation gave credence to he was
caught by two cops from little old
Winnipeg Canada tired of living life on
the run he began to tell the police
right down to the finest detail of how
he committed all his crimes some finger
criminal almost never does correcting
them where their investigation had
fallen short of the mark he even
revealed to them the location of the CC
star his grandmother's basement the
story ended with a complete 180 for
general Blanchard instead of trying to
beat the system he started to work for
it and helped it even going so far as to
credit the Winnipeg Police for helping
him to reform whether he'll ever returns
a crime remains to be seen but for now
there's never been a thief quite like
him in comic books there are few crime
lords more dangerous than the kingpin
but what if I was to tell you that real
life can offer someone much much worse
Miguel Angel Trevino Morales aka Z forty
might be one of the most dangerous and
vicious men who have ever lived his name
is synonymous with brutality and coupled
with the enormous power he once wielded
makes him one of the most deadly super
villains who has ever existed
Savino Morales began his criminal career
as a teenager when his father abandoned
him at a young age he was forced to step
up and provide for his entire family
early on he made some money tending to
the gardens of the wealthy something
which caused him to feel a growing
resentment towards the rich and he
eventually fell in with the lost hey
house gang he spoke fluent English and
had already gained experience moving
contraband across the us-mexico border
so for the gang he was an attractive
recruit over time he gained experience
in all facets of the drug trade from
smuggling to money laundering to
securing territory and winning drug wars
and eventually murder he rapidly
distinguished himself as a criminal
mastermind with an intense desire to be
the best at everything he did he never
took drugs himself he was an impeccable
marksman and instilled an extreme sense
of loyalty within those around him once
when he discovered that a band of heroin
addicts were terrorizing a local
neighborhood with petty crimes he had
his men round them up and kept them in
lockdown until they passed through
withdrawal and recovered from their
addiction and when they were clean he
put them to work it is says those same
addicts were so fiercely loyal to
Morales that they were murderously
jealous of anyone who gained his favor a
talented bold and vicious criminal
Morales rose through the ranks of latias
and when it was eventually consumed by a
larger gang he became the leader of the
Los Zetas drug cartel unique for his
frank and blunt approach to leadership
he would often tell his men to take
their own lives before they were
captured warning that they would
certainly be tortured then killed anyway
cope they may as well get it over with
it was here that his dark brutality came
to light he recruited teenagers as young
as 12 taught them to kill then
dispatched them on missions in the
United States and Mexico if he
discovered they had a particular fear or
ad version towards killing he would
personally oversee them cutting a
victim's head off and caving it in with
a hammer so that they'd lose their fear
it has been said by many that knew him
that he was unable to sleep if he hadn't
killed something that day he was said to
decapitate people himself asked his
victims how they would like to be
slaughtered and his preferred method of
execution was doing where he cooked
dozens of people alive in 50 gallon
barrels of burning hot oil
he left the mutilated headless bodies of
victims on street corners he dismembered
victims whilst alive and turned the Los
Zetas cartel into an international
conglomerate of drugs and violence that
reached all corners of the world it is
said if he wanted someone dead they
weren't safe no matter where in the
world's they may be his men would find
you and they would do far worse than
just kill you he responded to any
challenge to his authority with extreme
aggression and very few journalists
dared to write about him
his violence made him an almost
legendary
seemingly immune to gunfire fearless in
the face of death and inhumanly without
mercy many organization members claimed
he would drive around point to people at
random and ordered their death he would
also carve the letters ed into the
victims chest there were few things he
enjoyed more than the thrill of killing
as the Los Zetas territory expanded and
they took on their rival the Sinaloa
cartel they increased their brutality
leaving more bodies on roadsides and
dangling from bridges and in one
instance caused a disappearance and
slaughter of nearly 300 immigrants
seventy two of whom were later found
dead in one spot
the reason they likely refused to become
drug mules but most disturbing was a
game Morales like to play called who's
going to be the next hitman in 2011 he
captured several bus loads of immigrants
dragged them out into the deserts armed
them with weapons and told them the
rules of his game fight to the death the
last one standing gets to join the gang
terrified the result was a large
bloodbath of innocent people killing one
another out of self-preservation these
gladiator-style massacres were linked to
the deaths of over 190 people thankfully
Trevino Morales was captured by Mexican
Marines and his reign of terror did come
to an end but not before leaving behind
a history of violence and bloodshed
horrifying not just for its sadism but
for the fact that he actually happened
but of all the super villains out there
one stands out head and shoulders above
the rest
he has no discernible origin story he
has no clear motivation or plan no one
knows who he is where he came from or
what he's going to do next he just seems
to want to watch the world burn I'm of
course talking about the Joker but
whilst everyone's favorite Clown Prince
of Crime might seem like fiction the
truth is reality has provided someone
closer than you'd ever
expect one day for no reason at all a
highly paid computer systems
administrator by the name of Joseph
Konopka quit his job and began using the
internet to recruit a group of loyal
disciples the group's name was the realm
of chaos and Konopka took the moniker
dr. chaos the disciples were usually
teenagers delinquents Arno's compelled
to lash out against society using
abandoned tunnels that he picked the
locks too and had discovered by briefly
joining urban exploration groups Konopka
and his gang carried out dozens of
sabotage attacks across utility services
television broadcasts on even
air-traffic control causing
approximately 3 million u.s. dollars in
damages he also caused 28 power failures
and 20 service interruptions across all
of Wisconsin his target seemed to be
every imaginable component of civil
infrastructure even more disturbing is
that when Konopka or dr. chaos was
finally caught by the authorities it was
discovered he had stockpiled enormous
quantities of cyanide in the Chicago
subway tunnels
perhaps for a much larger and deadlier
attack the discovery caused a shutdown
of the red and blue subway lines whilst
authorities searched for more of the
substance
he was eventually sentenced to 21 years
in prison for two felony acts of
conspiracy to commit acts of terror as
well as six felony counts of arson and
vandalism as well as trespassing in
prison he was accused by the guards of
attempting to escape and was moved to a
supermax prison but whilst I have
included murderers crime lords and super
thieves in this video there's one reason
I decided to talk about dr. chaos and
the reason is rather simple no one
seemed to have any idea why he did what
he did
he just got up one day and decided to
wreak havoc on the world
he said only this to the district judge
I have several reasons but no real good
reason
he stockpiled cyanide and plotted the
disruption and destruction of key
infrastructure for seemingly no reason
at all he just wanted to so he did
Konopka has since been released from
prison and expressed regret for his
actions stating he meant no ill intent
for stockpiling the cyanide and he is
now interested in pursuing white hat
hacking as a career perhaps like general
Blanchard this reformed criminal might
be ideally placed in helping the very
systems he once sought to destroy but as
for why Konopka became dr. chaos and did
what he did nobody really knows and
perhaps we never will all we can say is
that there's never been a criminal quite
as enigmatic or mysterious as him thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
then please consider supporting me on
patreon it really helps me to continue
to make these videos the links in the
description also you can get your hands
on the first edition signed copy of my
new book stick if liked in it by heading
on over to unbound and pre-ordering
yours today the links in the description
thank you